now this seems like a losing strategy
insult the people you want to represent
so the matchup for florida's hotly
contested governor's race was set just
48 hours ago and democrat charlie crist
is already writing off nearly 4 million
republican voters
those who support the governor should
stay with them and vote for him and i
don't want your vote
if you have that hate in your heart keep
it there
i want the vote of the people of florida
who care about our state
he is on the battlefield of hate
i am on the battlefield of love and if
he wants to run on hate and culture wars
and dividing people and making people
hate each other that's his turf
it's not mine
i'm on a different plane
republican governor ron desantis firing
back
this is his fifth decade running for
office he's a chameleon typical career
politician but you know tucker people
support me because i kept the state open
and protected their jobs charlie crist
wanted it locked down so that's not hate
in their heart they're just appreciative
that they had a governor who was
standing up for them
in this election charlie crist is the
beta o'rourke of florida this nonsense
that
charlie crist is going to win in florida
against desantis to me is nonsense i'm
going to say that but uh charlie crist
did he just have a deplorables moment
no question about it if charlie crist is
going to win by almost every poll he's
got to convince the santos votes voters
to come to him it's like the pirates i
say the pirates declaring they refuse to
win the division i refuse to beat teams
that are better than me uh by all costs
pirates aren't good um thank you so yeah
i i don't want to wait for hammer to
define it tomorrow yeah it's in facebook
he used to be good willie starjoe um uh
manny sangian uh and roberto clementi uh
but but he here's the it's unbelievable
that he would say something like this
it's clear he wants to be the good guy
uh republican replaced jeb bush but for
he should his approach would be this i
know you're voting for ron desantis i
could do the same thing he can do only i
could do it x y and z but he just did
the biggest mistake that they did in
2016 and 2020. they vilified not donald
trump they vilified donald trump voters
that's what he just did in one day he
and the first day he had the nomination
he alienated two thirds of the
republican republicans judge you've run
for office can you imagine ever saying
something like this not in a million
years i wouldn't tell anybody i didn't
want their vote i would tell the devil i
wanted his vote as long as he voted look
here here's the problem you've got the
democrat party saying we're going to
unify everybody how do you unify people
when they say you're full of hate you're
no good i don't want your vote keep your
vote you pig i mean this is what they're
doing and that's just stupid because
he's been a democrat he's been an
independent and he's been a republican i
mean he's schizo i'm not sure who he
hates or who he wants hate but there's
another piece of this too it's not just
about this race it's about the national
race it's about his trying to create a
narrative that ronda santas is one of
the haters he's doing the national the
democrat national committee's uh work
and
in the end you know it's kind of like
jenny durkin from seattle you know we
got a summer of love and in the end she
did a total reverse course because it
doesn't work harold the democrats seem
to be sweating desantis already you know
before 2024
do they have reason to be concerned
uh probably because he's polling high in
some of the the republican uh
polling data around who would who people
would want if donald trump doesn't run
like i would take a different approach
than charlie chris i think he probably
been up late the night before i think
brian nailed it and saying you know you
democrats in 16 and 20 we did
it intentionally or not attacked the
voters you never attack voters voters
always get it right even if they don't
vote for you you got to figure out how
you get them to vote for you not attack
them for voting for someone else i think
what he said there at the end uh chris
charlie chris about he's about love and
his campaign is going to be about
inclusion he should just apologize to
voters i hope i didn't see that maybe he
did do that if he did if he didn't do it
he should apologize and say i didn't
mean it that way what i meant to say was
i'm going to make florida richer safer
healthier more secure with my plan and
lay out exactly the way brian just just
laid it out crime should be big cry he
should be talking crime he shouldn't be
talking about jessie
i'd be running around well i called him
charlie crispy seen his face yeah i need
some blocks he's like the tan dad he is
it wasn't just this that he said
everybody had hate in their hearts he
said joe biden i love him and he said
thank god for joe biden so he shot
himself in the foot twice and desantis
is going to wrap those two gaffs around
his burnt face
but the judge nailed it
he's not supposed to win he cut a deal
with the white house he had to run out
the wingnut left winger in the primary
then he gets in there and he just goes
scorched earth on desantis builds up a
big oppo file on the guy and says nice
things about joe biden probably invites
joe biden to florida yeah right and then
he goes down like a kamikaze and he gets
appointed to some place in the
administration that's the move but
desantis has to run up a big margin
against him because he needs like a
little political capital going
nationally so he'll have his work cut
out for him because there'll be a lot of
money coming in from out of state
against him but desantis will still do
well again i mean he's got a great
record he's got a a sharp tongue and
he's fearless really sharp not too long
ago
what a good line he said about fauci
within this last year i was in florida
and had needed to go from one place to
the next so i there was a taxi and the
driver said do you think ron desantis
will run for president i said i don't
know what do you think and he said i
hope he doesn't because i don't want to
lose my governor yes and i thought about
it
they like him a lot he's competent and a
leader hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else